GOOD MORNING WELCOME BACK TO SUB
FOR US IN ADMINISTRATION WITH
SEVENTEEN ITEMS ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR AND SIX OTHERS BE
HEARD.
WE WILL CALL STEPS QUORUM
PLEASE.
COOPER HERE BRO. CABALLERO. CHIU
CHOI NEAR.
TRAVELS FROM THE VOTE ONLY
COUNTER.
FACT A SECOND THAT ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
COOPER. I GROW.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
CHOI AYE
.
OR US OR OTHER NUMBER TWO.
THE ARTS COUNCIL LOCAL
PROGRAMMING AUGMENTATION
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA PAUSE ON THAT
SINCE MR CHOOSE NOT HERE. AND HE
WON'T TALK ABOUT THIS
.
WE'LL START WITH ISSUE NUMBER
DEPARTMENT HUMAN RESOURCES
BRING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE.
GOOD MORNING GENTLEMEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS PARTICULAR HAND DIRECTOR
OF.
KELLY CHAR. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
THE BCP BEFORE YOU.
A REALLY STARTED OUT OF THE THAT
A BROADER CONVERSATION. ISSUES
RELATED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BOTH ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT.
IN CALIFORNIA AND SACRAMENTO AS
WELL.
AND ON APRIL THIRD CABINET
SECRETARY KEELY BASEL HERE
ISSUED A DIRECTIVE TO CABINET.
CITING A NUMBER OF ACTIONS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GONNA TAKE
TO SO GET YOUR ARMS AROUND THIS
ISSUE.
I'M INCLUDING EXPANDED TRAINING
AND SUPPORT FOR E. OFFICERS AND
INVESTIGATORS.
UPDATING POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND INVESTIGATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE CONDUCTED
CONSISTENTLY. AND THOROUGHLY
ACROSS THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
UPDATED TRAINING CURRICULUM
MATERIALS FOR STATE EMPLOYEES.
OTHER EDUCATION OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND.
AND THE FOCUS OF THIS BE CP
WHICH IS ABOUT TRACKING AND
MONITORING THESE THINGS ARE
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO SINGLE
SOURCE. OF FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
REPORT. ALLEGATIONS ARE
COMPLAINTS. AS WELL AS FOLLOW
THEM THROUGH SORT OF THE LIFE
CYCLE TO CONCLUSION AND AND WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THAT SO.
THIS PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING
THREE POSITIONS AND ABOUT ONE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING. TO TO ESTABLISH A UNIT
WITHIN COLLEGE ARE THAT'S GOING
TO BE FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION BOTH REPORTING
AND TRACKING.
BUT ALSO IN AND DEVELOPING
PROCEDURES AND POLICIES AND
PUSHING THOSE THINGS OUT.
CONSULTING TO DEPARTMENTS AND
THEN LOOKING AT THE DATA FOR
TRENDS AND AND THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON EITHER BY
DEPARTMENT OR OR CROSS THE
STATE.
AND OF COURSE.
WITH THAT DATA WILL PROVIDE US
THE ABILITY TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR. ON
HOW WE'RE DOING.
WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE WHAT
WE'RE DOING ABOUT IT AND AND
PROVIDING MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TO THESE
MATTERS?
THANK YOU WEALTHY FINANCIER SAGA
ON THE ILLEGAL.
NOTHING. IT QUESTIONS LIKE
COMMITTEE.
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC QUESTIONS
BECAUSE ITEM.
I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADOPT THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL IS OUR MOTION.
GOT A MOTION A SECOND AT A LOCAL
POLICE.
COOPER I WROTE CABALLERO.
CHIU. CHOI.
THANK YOU.
PREVIOUSLY.
AND THEN THE NEXT ITEM.
BEFORE YOU IS A. RELATIVELY
STRAIGHT FOR PROPOSAL ON A NEW
TRAILER BILL. AND.
THIS DOVETAILS WITH THE
PROPOSAL THAT THIS COMMITTEES
ALREADY HEARD EARLIER IN THE
PROCESS RELATED TO EXPANDING
STATEWIDE TRAINING CENTER IN
THAT FOCUS ON. OUR STATE
EMPLOYEES TEACHING STATE
EMPLOYEES BOTH IN OUR BUILDING
ARE LEADERSHIP SKILLS AND OUR
MANAGEMENT SKILLS. ON.
BUT IT CAME TO LIGHT AX I THINK
AS A RESULT OF LEGISLATIVE STAFF
WARNING TO ATTEND ONE OF OUR
TRAINING COURSES.
AND A QUESTION AROSE IF WE HAD
THE AUTHORITY TO ALLOW.
.
INDIVIDUALS FROM OUTSIDE OF OF
STATE GOVERNMENT TO ATTEND OUR
TRAINING AND AND FOR US TO
CHARGE FOR THAT AND THIS WOULD
INCLUDE. A LEGISLATIVE STAFF
WOULD INCLUDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THINGS THAT MAKES US OUR OUR
LAWYERS TOOK A LOOK AT IT IN
INDETERMINATE LA WASN'T CLEAR
THAT THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS AND SO THIS
PROPOSALS. AS SIMPLY TO ALLOW US
TO OPEN UP OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
TO.
.
STAFF OF THE LEGISLATURE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO ATTEND A TRAINING AND
TIME OUT WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TIMING AND NOT HAVING THIS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT. THIS
ISSUE CAME UP LATE IN THE
PROCESS AND WE THOUGHT.
NOW IS A GOOD TIME AS ANY TO
TRY AND GET THE ISSUE BEFORE THE
WEBSITE.
BUT I THINK THAT TESTING JOB
OBVIOUSLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BEEN
DOING THAT FOR QUITE SOMETIME A.
FRIGGIN.
LEARN FROM THE MAKING TO FLEE
THEIR FROM US SO.
MUCH NEEDED I SEE FINANCES
STILL ABSENT ELLIOTT.
YOU QUESTION THE COMMITTEE.
ENTER THE PUBLIC WHICH IS BIG ON
THIS ITEM.
COUPLES PUBLIC COMMENT WHEN ALL
THIS ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU.
OKAY REBECCA ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
.
COMMISSIONER STATE MANDATES
LOCAL SYSTEMS
.
RECEIVED
GOOD MORNING DIXON AND START A
FINANCE.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THE
COMMISSION STATE MANDATES BUDGET
BE INCREASED BY THREE HUNDRED
TWELVE POINT TWO MILLION TO PAY
FOR FOURTEEN EXPIRED REPEALED
MANDATES.
WE KNOW THAT NINETY TWO PERCENT
OF THE THREE THREE HUNDRED
TWELVE POINT TWO MILLION
APPROPRIATE IN THE MAY REVISION.
IS OWED AS A RESULT OF MANDATES
ASSOCIATE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THE PURPOSES OF THE THIS
APPROPRIATION IS TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF OUTSTANDING DEBT THAT
IS OWED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
WRITTEN TO AUTHORIZES DEPARTMENT
FINANCE TO AUGMENT THIS AMOUNT.
AFTER PROVIDING JAIL BC
NOTIFICATION IF THE INITIAL
APPROPRIATION IS INSUFFICIENT BY
THE PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST.
ON THESE AT THAT IDENTIFIED
MANDATE CLAIMS.
AT THIS SUMMIT BECAUSE I TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE BUT YOU REALLY UP.
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE FROM OHIO WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS THIS WILL
REDUCE THE STATE'S.
OUTSTANDING PAYMENTS RICARDO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM AND IT'S.
YOU QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE.
A LOT OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT
INTUITION SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD MORNING DOROTHY JOHNSON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ALLOCATION FOR I COUNTIES
AND ALSO OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS FOR SERVICES WE'VE
ALREADY RENDERED. AND APPRECIATE
THIS RECOGNITION OF THE DATA IN
TERMS OF AYE PAIN DOWN THE
LONGER STANDING DUES TO COUNTIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HER
STEERED HIM BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS OF THAT COUNTIES
OF. RIVERSIDE MENTOR AND SANTA
CRUZ IN SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU ARE CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
RECOGNITION TO DOT THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL THEIR MOTION.
KAMALA MOTIONS SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER I THROW CABALLERO.
CHIU. CHOI.
CONNECTS ITEM WE.
ISSUE NUMBER TO OUR COUNCIL
LOCAL PROGRAMMING AUGMENTATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHU GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
A UP FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO THINK
THE GOVERNOR FOR ADDING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE MAY REAP.
REVISED FOR CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL.
THE GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUES AN IMPORTANT
INDICATOR OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS PROGRAM.
THIS C. A. C. HOUSE A DIVERSE
SET OF PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS.
SERVING VETERANS UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SCHOOL CHILDREN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AND
MORE.
THE IMPACT OF OF DECEASED SEE IS
FELT IN EVERY LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICT.
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE DEMAND FOR THE GRAND IS NOT
BEING MET EACH YEAR.
AND THE DEMAND IS GROWING.
ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT OF%
THE GRANT APPLICATION ONE
UNFUNDED AND I LAST YEAR. AND
THERE WAS A ABOUT SURETY TO
PARTAKE INCREASE IN APPLICATION
FROWN TO PRIOR YEAR.
THE CDC SUPPORTS COMMUNITY
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND AND THE HOUSE BEING A SOURCE
OF BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT.
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO LAG
BEHIND OTHER STATE WHEN IT COMES
TO INVESTING IN ART.
RECENT BUDGET IMPROVEMENT HAVE
TAKEN THOSE FROM THE BACK OF
TUPAC TO THE MIDDLE OFF TO PACK.
BUT WE SHOULD ASPIRED TO DO
BETTER.
S. OF. OF THE CREATIVITY OF
CREATIVE ECONOMY IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND THIS IS WHY I'M
SEEKING AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS PING PONG GOING.
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL IN I URGE TO YOU YOUR
AYE VOTE WILL HAVE A PEOPLE
TESTIFY. YOU TAKING.
THE A SUPPORTIVE BY TESTIMONY.
YES ARE
PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN COOPER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR HEARING US WE'RE GRATEFUL.
MY NAME IS DAN BROWN CRAWFORD
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
CAO MORE GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR THIS ADDITION TO
OUR BUDGET.
WE PLAN TO USE THE ADDITION TO
FUND SOME OF THE.
MENTIONED UNMET NEEDS IN THIS
GREAT STATE. APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY PERCENT OF OUR REQUESTS
GO UNFUNDED THIS YEAR AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT PERCENTAGE TO
GROW NEXT YEAR. YEAH I'M FOR
EXAMPLE JUMPSTART'S.
A PROGRAM THAT AND.
ITS OPERATING WITHIN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE
PROGRAM.
.
HAD A THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
INCREASE IN APPLICATIONS ALL BY
ITSELF. THIS YEAR ADAM.
RE ENTRY THROUGH THE ARTS THIRTY
TWO PERCENT INCREASE.
ARTS EDUCATION WE HAVE A TWENTY
PERCENT INCREASE IN APPLICATIONS
WHICH IS VERY MEANINGFUL FOR US
AND WE'D LIKE TO MEET THAT NEED.
WE ALSO PLAN TO EVALUATE OUR
EXISTING.
GRANTS PROGRAMS THROUGH HIGH
QUALITY RESEARCH.
SO THAT WE RECEIVE RESULTS THAT
ARE BOTH CREDIBLE AND
INDEPENDENT. EVALUATION. OF FOR
OUR ORGANIZATION.
HOPE SAYS TO SEE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF WHAT WE DO AS A
LARGE GROUP BUT ALSO WE WOULD WE
WOULD LIKE TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE SMALLER
NETWORKS THAT WE HAVE IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. OF THE
STATE.
M. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
NONPROFITS RELY TO ASSESS THE
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY OF OUR WORK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THEIR
CAPACITY BUILDING MEASURE THE
IMPACT OF AUDIENCE IN COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND ASSESS LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT FOR ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. A QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU
YOU A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS AND
YOU'VE EVALUATED ONE OF YOU THAT
BY WITH ALL THE PROGRAMS ARE WE
HAVE EVALUATED OTHER PROGRAMS
AND ALL BUT I MIGHT DEPUTIES.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE SOCIETY ON
A KEYBOARD AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
AND YES WE DO HAVE HISTORY OF
EVALUATING OUR GRANTS PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE THE JUMPSTART PROGRAMS
THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING EVALUATED
THAT'S THE PROGRAM THAT'S
PROVIDES ART SERVICES.
FOR YOUTH THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM WE
WERE WE WERE FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE AN AUGMENTED ACT RAPPER.
GRANT PROGRAM LAST YEAR AND NOW
WE'VE EXPANDED ITS FOR THE
DIVISION OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SO WE WANT TO EVALUATE THAT
PROGRAM. AND WE ALSO HAVE A RE
ENTRY GRANT PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
EVALUATING ELIGIBLE PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN EXIST IN EXISTENCE
ALONG. OTHER JUMPSTART'S PROGRAM
HAS BEEN AROUND A BELIEVE FOR
THREE THREE YEARS THIS IS THE
PERSON WHO FIRST EVALUATION AS
TO EXACTLY OKAY THAT THAT WAS
THAT WAS A QUESTION THAT RAY AND
I REENTRY GRANT PROGRAM IS BEEN
AROUND FOR TWO YEARS AND WE'RE
EVALUATING THAT NOW.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
FINANCE.
MISTER CHAIR WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT THE ARTS COUNCILS GRANT
PROGRAMS CAN ACHIEVE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES UP WE
BELIEVE THE POST FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IS AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF INVESTMENT FOR THE COUNCIL.
WE'RE CONCERNED THEIR GREATER
INFLEXIBLE ENDING MIGHT STRAIN
THE OUR COUNCIL'S EXISTING
PERSONAL RESOURCES I'M A GREATER
EMPHASIS ON IN MEANS AN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE PROCESS AN
INCREASE IN APPROVALS BEING
REPROCESSED.
AN INCREASE IN THE NEED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO GRANTEES
AND ARE ALSO AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER VALUATIONS OF THE PROGRAM
SO THEREFORE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF INVESTMENT
THIS TIME.
LL.
HOW ENCOURAGED HIM AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
WE THINK THAT THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING FOR THE ARTS COUNCIL IS
LARGELY MODEL MATTER OF POLICY
PRIORITIES FOR THE LEGISLATURE?
THAT WE WOULD KNOW HOWEVER THERE
IS RELATIVELY LIVE LIMITED
EVIDENCE ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
RUN TO THE ARTS COUNCIL.
AND SOME OF THE EVIDENCE THAT
WE DO YOU HAVE.
IT ISN'T ALWAYS AS ROBUST AS WE
WOULD LIKE IT IS.
SORT OF.
AS CREDIBLE AND INDEPENDENT AND
SO WE THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT THIS
FUNDING WOULD ALLOW FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL EVALUATION.
BUT JUST A GOOD A WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT THE IT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER I'M ASKING
YOUR ATTEMPTS OF COUNSEL FOR
SOME MORE DETAILS ON HOW. HOW IN
FACT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
FUNDING IS CREDIBLE THANK YOU
MISTER CHIU?
I WANT TO JUST OUTSIDE.
PORT THE CHAIR OF THE ARTS
ENTERTAINED COMMITTEE AND HIS
SUGGESTION THAT WE INCREASE OF
FUNDING I THINK WE ALL KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT.
THE ARTS ARE TO OUR STATE WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR EDUCATION WHEN
IT COMES TO ECONOMY WHEN IT
COMES TO TOURISM.
EVEN WITH THE ADVANCES WERE
SEEN WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AND AND
ARTS PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE WITH
INDIVIDUALS WERE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
ARTS FOR ARTS SAKE.
THIS IS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
ASSET FOR OUR STATE A IT WASN'T
LONG AGO THAT WE AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE DEAD LAST IN PER
CAPITA FUNDING FOR THE ARTS.
THINK NOW MOST RECENT ITHACA SO
WHERE THIRTY FIFTH AND TRYING TO
CLIMB UP BUT WE SHOULD WE SHOULD
BE LEADING THAT AND SO I WOULD.
SUPPORT AND I DO HOPE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS WILL BE ABLE TO
GET THAT NUMBER HIGHER I HAVE TO
ADMIT.
ON HEARING THE PROBLEM FINANCES
PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU MAY NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO CARRY THIS
OUT. THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
CONVERSATION BUT IT STRIKES ME
ARE WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T NEED
THAT MANY RESOURCES TO DISPERSE
ANOTHER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
FUNDING IF THAT'S A WE GET
THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO. I VERY
MUCH HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND A WAY
TO DO THIS.
CERTAINLY WITH AN ALMOST NINE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A SPECKLED
BUDGET DUST TO GET US TO A
BETTER PLACE SO.
I JUST WANTED EXPRESS THAT.
WITH CARRIER.
SO I'M I'M THIS IS GOING TO BE A
AN ITEM THAT'S GOING TO BE HELD
OPEN AYE AYE ONE AT SECOND WHAT.
MY COLLEAGUE SAID HOWEVER MY
EXPERIENCE IN MANY GRANT
PROGRAMS IS THAT THOSE THAT KNOW
HOW TO GET THE MONEY ARBOR EXIT
SUCCESSFUL AND THOSE THAT DON'T.
AREN'T VERY SUCCESSFUL AND SO
RURAL COMMUNITIES TEND NOT TO
GET VERY MUCH AND WHEN THEIR
STATE LIMITED STATE RESOURCES SO
I'D LIKE TO KNOW. JUST IN TERMS
OF YOUR GRANT PROGRAM.
.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW HAVE YOU
ENSURED THAT THERE'S A.
BROAD BASE OF OF.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITIES
IT MAY NOT A AND I I'VE HAD A
SERIES OF OF BUT CAN
NEIGHBORHOOD MEETINGS AND IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF ON THE OUTS
FOR SOME KIND OF ARTS PROGRAM.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT IN IN THAT
COUNTY OF MONTEREY THAT ARTS
MONEY THAT GOES OUT THE MAJORITY
OF IT GOES TO THE MONTEREY
PENINSULA.
AS OPPOSED TO THE SALINAS
VALLEY AND SO I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE END UP ON
DISTRIBUTING FUNDS AS BROADLY AS
POSSIBLE.
SO I AM FIRST OF ALL I I COME TO
THIS AGENCY WEARING THE RURAL
ADVOCACY HAT. AND THEM I AM VERY
PLEASED TO WEAR IT IT'S ALSO THE
NEA SEE.
CAO FOCUS TO HELP US REACH
RURAL COMMUNITIES I THINK IT'S
VITAL WHEN I SAY THAT WE SHOULD.
HAVE A PRESENCE IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IF I FEEL THAT
VERY STRONGLY I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO EMPHASIZE IT MORE THAN SAY.
THEIR OF CENTER FOLKS OUT IN OUR
STATE THAT ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY
DISPOSSESSED FROM.
LARGE URBAN AREAS FROM THE
COAST AND THEY DESERVE OUR
ATTENTION JUST AS MUCH AS
ANYBODY ELSE.
IN THE.
AND ADD THAT PART OF OUR
INVESTMENT IN IN OUR RESEARCH IS
TO IDENTIFY HOW WE CAN REACH
THOSE COMMUNITIES HAVE GOING TO
BEEF UP OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
PROVIDE SOME WORKSHOPS AND OTHER
ACCESS POINTS TO OUR GRANTS
PROGRAMS BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE
BEEN USING A CERTAIN WAYS THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
AND IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE FAR REACHING. YOU KNOW THAT
WE REACH ALL OF THE AREAS OF THE
STATE THEY NEED THE SUPPORT.
THE EAGLES INFORMATIONAL HOW THE
LAST GRANTS WERE DISPERSED IF
THEY WANT TO RURAL COMMUNITIES
AT ALL THEY DID.
AND.
I THINK THEY DID GO TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE WE HAVE AN
EDUCATION PROCESS
WHAT WHAT FIRST OF ALL WE TRY
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS IS WELL
KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
THEN WE HAVE AN ADJUDICATION
PROCESS WHERE WE A PANELIST
SITTING. ON IT ON THE OTHER.
ON THE PANEL SETS REDUNDANT BUT.
TO ACTUALLY.
AND WE'D WE CHOOSE PANELISTS
THAT ARE FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
RURAL AND URBAN AS WELL AS IT
BEING EXPERTS IN THE FIELD FOR
WHATEVER GRANT AWARD. AND
PROGRAM THERE ADJUDICATING. AND
THAT THAT WAY WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE EYES ON. THAT HAS A DUAL
FOLD PURPOSE AND WHEN WE HAVE
PANELISTS COME IN FROM RURAL
AREAS THEY'RE LEARNING ABOUT THE
PROCESS THEY GO BACK TO THEIR
REGIONS. AND THEN THAT THEN THEY
CAN TALK MORE AND EDUCATE MORE
PEOPLE ON HOW TO APPLY SO IT.
IT'S CYCLICAL.
WE CAN ALSO PROVIDE TO A LIST OF
ALL OF I. ROLE PANTIES IF THAT
WOULD HELP. IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
AND WITH THE SAME PROBLEM THE
FOR THE BIGGER CITIES TO GET
EATEN. AS LARGER STATIONS KYLE
BRING A LOT OF HELP THEY'LL BE
HELPFUL TO THINK WE WILL DO
THAT.
A GOING UP. MISTER CHOI.
OKAY IN CONCEPT I WOULD ALSO A
SUPPORT THAT UP BUT IF YOU WITH
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE. LOOKING AT
THE PAST OF THREE YEARS SO FAR
EXPENDITURES SO.
LIMON A FEW ITEMS SO I SEE KEEP
ARTS A IN SCHOOL REFUND THAT
THAT IS SO. LOWEST OF FUNDING
AND THEN I THINK OF TIPPING OFF
SCHOOL WHIMS IN SPORTS IS A VERY
VERY. IMPORTANT.
AND DAY IN MY.
.
THE DISTRICT AREA.
WHERE I'M MORE COMFORTABLE
UNDERSTANDING DOES THE OR THE
PROGRAM SO OFF PROGRAM SO IN THE
CITY OF IRVINE? IRVINE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT OUT BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF FUNDING. DISTRUST OR
SUPPORTED ARTS PROGRAM FOR
SUPPORTED A FROM THE YEAR.
PROFIT UP FOUNDATION FUND
RAISING RECORD FUND OF
FOUNDATION FUND RAISING EFFORTS
UP I ONE DAY FOR TEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO WOULD MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE. IN NOW MORE FUNDING
FOR THIS TO SCHOOL. POSSIBLE
WHIMS RIGHT. CAN I AM SO THE KEY
PARTS IN SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE
VOLUNTARY TAX
A CHECK OFF OF FUND SO THAT IS
THE YOU KNOW TAX FUN AND THAT WE
HAVE AND WE. LAST YEAR WE HAD
SOME CHALLENGES WITH OUR.
.
THE TURBO TAX.
MESSAGING SO WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF DEPTH THAT'S BEEN CORRECTED
SO WE WILL BE CONTINUING TO. TO
GO OUT AND GET REVENUES FROM
THAT FUND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THAT FUNDING THAT
WE CONTINUE OUR ROBUST MARKETING
OF THAT BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW A COMMITMENT THAT WE
HAVE TO DIVERSIFY OUR FUNDING
DAYS BUT OUR ARTS EDUCATION. ARE
GRANT PORTFOLIO HAS ONLY BEEN
EXPANDED WE'VE EXPANDED IT FROM
ARTS IN SCHOOL TO ART AFTER
SCHOOL AND BEFORE SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND IN ADDITION THIS
LAST YEAR. WE HAVE AN ARTS
EXPOSURE PROGRAM WHICH IS A
PROGRAM TO OFFER I'M LOW INCOME
ITS STUDENTS IN THE SCHOOLS
OPPORTUNITIES TO GO TO ART
EXHIBITS AND ARTS PRESENTATIONS.
SO OUR ACTUAL ARTS GRANTS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN EXPANDED AND WE
HAVE A HUGE AMOUNT OF UNMET NEED
THERE THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
INCREASED APPLICATIONS AND. YOU
KNOW JUST BECAUSE OF OUR FUNDING
RIGHT NOW WE ARE SEEING STILL OF
A LARGE PERCENTAGE THAT GO
UNFUNDED.
BEARD LARGEST EXPENDITURE CUT
THE WARRIORS SO.
.
WHAT ARE OBVIOUSLY GENERAL FUND
ABOUT THAT THE OTHER ONE IS?
?
THE.
NO REIMBURSEMENT THE ARE EIGHT
OVER EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO IS
THIS A GRANT APPLICATION ON
LOCAL BASIS RIGHT SO OUR
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM COMES
THROUGH GENERAL FUND FROM THE
SKY CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF.
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
SO IT'S GENERAL FUND THAT GOES
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION AND COMES TO
US THEIR INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT
REIMBURSEMENT SO IT'S IT'S A VCR
GENERAL FUNDS THAT COME TO THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. FOR US
TO RUN OUR ARTS IN CORRECTIONS
IT IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM OUR
GRANTS PROGRAM FEELS ARE ALL
CAO.
CONTRACTED PROGRAMMING THAT IS
DOING THE WORK OF CDC ARE IN THE
INSTITUTIONS IN THE EYE AND THE
ADULT.
AND INSTITUTIONS.
WITHIN CDC ARE SO IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT THAT'S OUR
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM THAT IS
NOT RELATED TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE WHICH IS THE
FIVE MINUTE MILLION DOLLAR
ARGUMENT TO OUR GRANTS PROGRAM
THAT'S.
THE DIFFERENT CEREMONY.
I WONDER.
IF UP ASSEMBLYMAN TRUE.
YOU HAVE ANY RECOMMENDED
THE AREAS A HOLIDAY AND MILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL IT CAN.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THE HOSTESS
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED.
I I I THINK DELEON A WILL CAN
JUST CONTINUE REACHING OUT TO
YOU KNOW SERVING THE RULER
AREAS.
ON THE VETERANS SENATE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
TO SCHOOL CHILDREN AND
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES SO BUT
BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I OF ALL WE WILL.
PUBLIC BE IT GET ALL WILL GET
INVOLVED WITH THE PLANNING AFTER
WE KNOW DATA MONIES COMMENT I
MEAN WHAT RIGHT NOW I I GUESS MY
QUESTION LAST A WITH A TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WAS A JUSTIFIED
THAT BECAUSE OF.
THE.
OF FROM THE EXPERIENCE WHAT
THROUGH APPLICATIONS AT THAT
DOWN THE NUMBER WAS TO DEFINE GO
OR ONCE IT GOT TEN MILLION
ORGANIZED TO ADD TO MORE OR WHAT
WAS IT JULY OF MENTAL NOTE YOU
KNOW I LIKE TO SEE MORE ON THE
OF. THE SHIP THE VETERAN
SERVICES.
AN HOUR AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY.
SCHOOL CHILDREN AND CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES.
AND JR MAINLY IN GENERAL
PUBLIC'S A CAN CAN YOU ELABORATE
THAT WHAT THE QUESTION ORDERED
FACILITIES SOMEHOW THIS ARTS
PROGRAM WOULD WORK FOR THEM
OWNER WILL HELP A LOT OF TO. THE
PEOPLE THAT GO INTO. THE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES TO A TO
EDUCATE THEM AND TAKE. TO HELP
THEM ILL DEVELOP SOME SKILL AND
APPRECIATION OF ART
AND AND. OUR THE TYPE PROBABLY
HELP IN THIS DO. REPORT AS WELL
SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO START MY
BURIED ON THEIR. BLOG EXACTLY
WOULD DO IN THE CLERK
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY I THINK
YOU'RE SPOT ON ABOUT THAT I. ARE
IT'S A POWERFUL PROGRAM IN ARTS
IN CORRECTIONS IT DOESN'T.
SIMPLY TEACH APPRECIATE FOR
SHIZHEN FOR THE ARTS IT DOWN IT
TEACHES.
I WAS ONCE A PRISONERS BUT
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE I'M IN
AGREEMENT TO INMATES.
IT HOW TO DEVELOP EMPATHY. HOW
TO EXPRESS EMOTION AND HOW IT
HOW TO INTERACT ON A TEAM BUT IT
HOW? IT GIVES THEM A.
.
INTERPERSONAL SKILLS THAT ARE
NOT BEING DEVELOPED WHILE
THEY'RE IN.
THE YARD THICK AND ACTUALLY
CHANGES THE NATURE OF WHAT GOES
ON IN THE YARD
IN IT BECOMES CLOSER TO. A
COMMUNITY THAT THEY WILL REENTER
INTO ONCE AGAIN OUTSIDE OF THE
PRISON.
SO THEY'RE TRANSFERABLE SKILLS
THAT ARE TAUGHT THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS
SO THIS WAY I'M GOING TO PUT
PUBLIC COMMENT IN WHICH THERE
BECOMES OUT OF IN THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CHRIS
ATCHISON SHELTER ABOUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES JUST
OBVIOUSLY ONE THINK THE GOVERNOR
FOR INCLUDING THIS MAY REVISE
BUT ALSO AN ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LEADERSHIP THAT'S BEEN SHOWN BY
THIS COMMITTEE OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS OF THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO KEEP WORKING WITH YOU.
ARE EXPANDING THE ARTS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU RECOGNITION
THE LOS LOBOS LITTLE HAND HELD
OPEN.
NEXT ONE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
NO ACT CALIFORNIA ELECT BOARD
WILL CLOSING. PARDON.
OKAY MY
CLOSING OF NO.
IF YOU. MISTER CHIU ABSOLUTELY
CAN'T HOW IT COULD I JUST FOLLOW
THROUGH BETTER SHORTLY TO SAY
ARTS IS HUMANITY.
SO I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT OF
HUMANITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXUS CALIFORNIA ELECT BOARD
CONTINUE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA ABLE PROGRAM.
CONTRACT TWENTY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ABLE PROGRAM
MORNING GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
THAT DANTE ALLEN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE.
.
CAL ABLE ACT PORT.
NOW WE ARE HERE TODAY WITH.
.
THE ESSENTIALLY TO REQUEST ONE
IS A NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR SIDE GENERAL FUND LOAN
ALLOCATION. OF THAT GROUNDCOVERS
PRIMARILY THE OPERATIONS OF THE.
CALLIE BOWL. A THINK CLICKS
FIVE THREE STAFF MEMBERS ARE AND
CONSULTANT DOLLARS AND.
WHAT'S SOME MARKETING COSTS
WHILE WE ARE OPEN IN OPERATIONS.
AND THEN THE ADDITIONAL FROM
THE.
.
MAY REVISION IS ASKING IN
ADDITION A ONE POINT. ONE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD.
PROVIDE US WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTRACT WITH THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR THAT WILL HANDLE.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PORTIONS OF
THE.
CAO ABLE.
PROGRAM.
AND RECORD KEEPING INVESTMENT
SERVICES SO IT IS A.
ABOUT OUR SERVICES.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
DOMINIC CARE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH. THE ENTIRE REQUEST ELIA.
I SO WE WOULD KNOW THAT WHEN WE
ANALYZE THE JANUARY PROPOSAL WE
NOTED THAT IT WAS UNLIKELY THAT
THE BOARD WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE SINCE.
SELF SUFFICIENCY WITHIN THE AYE
STATUTORILY GUIDED AYE TIMELINE
AND SO WE HAD RECOMMENDED AT
THAT TIME THAT THE BOARD COME
BACK NEXT YEAR AND REPORT ON. ON
HOW IT MIGHT ACHIEVE THAT
SUSTAINABILITY.
WITH THIS MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS AN ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND LOAN I'M IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
EVEN LESS LIKELY THAT THEY'LL
ACHIEVE THAT SELF SUFFICIENCY.
AYE SORA CONDITION WITH THE HIGH
TECH ASK THE BOARD. IF THEY HAVE
A PLAN FOR SELF SUSTAINABILITY.
IT'S OF SUFFICIENCY ON ITS OF
WHAT THEY THINK THE LIKELIHOOD
OF THAT IS AND ALSO JUST TO CUT
A FLAG FOR THE LEGISLATURE THAT.
IT DOES APPEAR LIKE THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT LIKELIHOOD THAT I'M
GOING TO FUND SUPPORT WILL BE
NEEDED FOR THIS PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THOUGHT TO CLARIFY THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THIS ITEM
SHOULD BE TO APPROVE HAS
BUDGETED. IN JANUARY RESOURCES
ADOPT THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSAL.
IN QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WITH YOUR MOTION.
BUT AMOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
POLICE COOPER BY.
CABALLERO.
CHIU. CHOI.
THE NEXT MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
ITEM A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FINANCING LOCAL ASSISTANCE
.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN TOOK SOME
IT'S DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION REQUEST TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL NINE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITION
TO THE TWENTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION REQUEST IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FIRST COUNTY
CITIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS FOR
PROPERTY TAX LOSSES.
RESULTING FROM THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES AND
RESULTANT MONTHS FLIGHTS THIS
WOULD MAKE A TOTAL PREPARATION
THIRTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION.
THE FINAL PROPERTY TAX LOSS
ESTIMATES INDICATE TWENTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR THE
SEVEN COUNTIES NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND ELEVEN MILLION
FOR THE FIVE COUNTIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH C.
SACK IN THE COUNTY OTHER
CONTROLLERS TO CLICK THE LOSS
ESTIMATES.
WE NOTE THAT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE HAS BEEN WRITTEN TO
AUTHORIZE THE ADDITIONAL PAYMENT
OF PROPERTY TAX LOSSES. IF THE
AMOUNT APPROPRIATED IS
INSUFFICIENT TO BACKFILL ACTUAL
LOSSES
AT THIS TIME I'D BE GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ACTUALLY IS
RESOURCES ARE IMPORTANT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED BY THE
FIRES.
.
PLEASE PLEASE EXPLAIN HOW
ALLOCATIONS WERE DETERMINED.
WE WERE WE WERE WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY OTHER CONTROLLERS WHO
WORK WITH THEIR OWN COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S.
AND THEY'D LOOK AT THE THE
ACTUAL PARCELS THAT WERE DAMAGED
BY THE FIRE OR THE MUDSLIDES AND
THE ASSESSORS.
.
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION TO COME
OUT OUR CONTROLLERS AND THEY'VE.
I RELAYED THE INFORMATION TO US
SO IT'S ACTUAL COUNTY WORK.
.
THAT DATA GAVE US THAT THE
ACTUAL ESTIMATES
THANK YOU ELLIOTT.
ONE THING THAT WE WOULD HAVE
ASSEMBLY HIGHLIGHT IS THAT.
AND THAT WE INCLUDED IN THE
BROADER AYE RESPONSE THE
WILDFIRES EARLIER IN THE BUDGET
SEASON.
IS THAT AT THE MOMENT THE STATE.
IS IN A FINANCIAL POSITION TO
BE ABLE TO COMPLETELY BACK FOR A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LOSSES.
I AS A RESULT OF THESE WILDFIRES
HOWEVER IN THE FUTURE THE STATE
MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
THE SAME SORT OF THING. AND
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
WHETHER THERE ARE CRITERIA BY
WHICH TO DO TODAY THEIR CRITERIA
BY WHICH TO DETERMINE WHICH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD RECEIVE.
FROM A BACK FILL IN WHAT
PROPORTION OVER WHAT I'M TIME
PERIOD.
AS AN EXAMPLE SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE MY MORE EASILY RECOVER IN
TERMS OF REBUILDING THE PROPERTY
IS WHERE AS OTHERS THERE MIGHT
USE A SIGNIFICANT LAG.
PARTICULARLY IN FUTURE.
DISASTERS AND WE WERE JUST
HIGHLIGHT THIS ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
DOCTOR CHOI.
YEAH READING HERE.
.
THE GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET. IS SO
FOR WHAT OVER TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS SO FULL ON IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE OF FIVE RELATED POP TO
TEXAN LOSSES OF BECAUSE A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ROSI'S Y. ON
NO ONE AT THAT TIME.
THAT'S A VERY STRANGE RIGHT
AFTER THE FIRE I DUTY
INDIA TOUR OF THAT THAT DAMAGED
AREAS. THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY I
COULD TELL HOW MANY HOMES WERE
DAMAGED. NEW Y. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WAS ARE NOT THE
MORE DAMAGES WHAT DONE AND THEN
JUST WERE. ASSESSED.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF DAMAGES
ARE INSTALLING CALIFORNIA ONE
NOT PROCESSED. VERY STRANGE.
WHEN WE DEVELOPED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT WAS BACK IN
DECEMBER.
AND A LOT OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ASSESSORS HAD HAD
GONE HADN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
GO OUT AND ACTUALLY ASSESS THE
DAMAGE AT THAT TIME WHO HAS TO
PULL OUT THE ARE UNCLEAR.
THE UP WAS JEFF HEY OUT
LOGICALLY AND TEN OR SO ARE.
DE AFFECTED AREA THAT IN THAT
AREA I SAW ANAHEIM FILES ONLY
T..
A FIRE DEPARTMENT IDEA TO OUR
MAJOR AUTHORITIES WAS HALF A
AMEND THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT THE
PROPERTY DAMAGE YOU SAID THEY
SELF AT THAT TIME.
IT TAKES AWHILE WHY DOESN'T
SOMEBODY HAVE TO GO ON WITH GOD
EXTEND IT TOOK AWHILE FOR THE
THE ASSESSORS TO ACTUALLY
IDENTIFIED THE DAMAGE FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL PARCEL.
IT'S NOT ON AND ON IT OVERALL
AREA BASES THEY NEED TO.
TO ASSESS.
THAT THE PROPERTY TAX LOSSES
FOR EACH EACH INDIVIDUAL ITEM
EVEN TOOK THE PICTURES HE SAYS
OF VERY CLEAR WHAT KIND OF
DAMAGE IS ALMOST TO THE DOES THE
BOND ONCE WAS APPLAUDED OFFICE
RIGHT.
WELL WE WE REACH OUT TO THE
COUNTIES IN AND THEY HADN'T
COMPILE THAT INFORMATION FORCE
AT THE TIME OF OF THE CREATION
OF OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE ADDED THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AT THIS TIME.
SO WHY SO THIS IS.
ASSESSED APPEAR THAT.
AND NUMBER ABA DAMAGES ASSESSED
A HOW ARE YOU KNOW AUGMENT DATA.
AB THAT'S THE INCLUDING A
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IF THERE'S
ANY.
ANY DIFFERENCE
UP FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN WE BACK FIELD THE PROPERTY
TAX LOSSES FOR RELATING
CALAVERAS COUNTY.
I IT TOOK THEM TOOK THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S AWHILE TO ACTUALLY
FIND OUT THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGES.
AND THE ACTUAL AMOUNT OF OF FAT
PROPERTY TAX LOSSES FOR THOSE
TWO COUNTIES.
AND DATA.
WE'RE GIVING OURSELVES AN EXTRA
LITTLE BIT OF TIME AYE IF THERE
IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WAS
ESTIMATED IN THE ACTUAL. WILL BE
ABLE TO.
.
COMPLETELY BACKFILL PROVIDE YOU
KNOW SO.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROPERTY TAX
LOSSES ARE COMPLETELY REPAID AND
THE COUNTIES ARE MADE WHOLE.
SO EXACTLY DON'T A LOT MORE
MUSCLE TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS SOMEHOW WOULD THIS BE
FUNDS BE YOU STE.
AT THAT THE FUNDING GOES TO
REDUCE THAT. THINK THE COUNTY'S
MOSTLY RELY ON PROPERTY TAXES.
A FURTHER FOR THE REVENUE
SOURCES AND THIS WILL DON'T BE
SO QUICK TO COUNTY IT WILL GO TO
THE COUNTIES.
CITIES AND THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ALL THREE OF THEM ARE BEING BACK
FILLED FOR THEIR LOSSES.
OKAY SO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
PORTION WOULD BE ADDED LATER ON
ALL THE STATE'S OTHER CALPERS
FROM CALIFORNIA PORTION IS ABOUT
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND IS
ADDED IN OUR HOME.
OUR ESTIMATES FOR FOR MAY REVISE
IN THIS BUT IN THIS BUDGET YES
SIR THANK.
WE FOR THE QUESTION WHO
COMMITTEE.
GOING UP NOW BUT PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESTORED THE JOHNSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ALLOCATION TO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY WORK
SO CLOSELY OF DE LAUGH. TO GET
AN ACCURATE NUMBER OF THE LOSSES
TO COUNTIES FOR PROPERTY TAX
NEEDS.
THE DEVASTATION CONTINUES AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO OUR LOCAL
ASSESSMENTS AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IT AFFORDS US THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND TIME TO MAKE
SURE IT'S AN ACCURATE ALLOCATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AT MEMBERS KAREN
LANG ON GOV OF THE NAPA CINEMA
AND MENDOCINO PARTS OF
SUPERVISORS ALL VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE GOVERNOR OF BASICALLY
COMING TO THE RESCUE ON THE
PARTY TALKS BACK PHIL. NEWBY
REMISS I THINK IT HERE FAST
ENOUGH ON THE FIRST ITEM RELATED
TO THE MAN MANDATES CINEMA
COUNTY VERY SPECIFICALLY SAYS
THANK YOU THAT WILL LITERALLY
SAVE JOBS AND SOME COUNTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH BUT THOSE THINGS
TODAY. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE TO APPRECIATE
THAT ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING.
ON THE PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL
VENTURA COUNTY'S LOSSES ARE A
UPWARDS OF FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
AND I WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE I WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOVERY EFFORTS.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CAROL SUMMING UP
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT OF FUNDING
FOR BACKFILL FOR US SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOING IS THE CHAIR
MEMBERS MUSTAFA IS SAUDI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THIS FUNDING ENERGY SPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOING CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT OTHER
CONDITIONS TO ADOPT THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL IS OUR MOTION.
MY FIRST THE SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER. BY HAVING AERO.
TO.
CHOI.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR HEARING WE
BECKON COMMITTEE ON MONDAY
AFTERNOON WITH AFTER SESSION.
MY FRIENDS